cuál es la diferencia que existe entre
vivir o morir si han hecho esa pregunta
quedo contrario de morir
y muchos dicen vivir
hay personas que han sobrevivido y hay
otras personas que son supervivientes
que a veces uno necesita estar al filo
de la muerte para agarrarse con todas
sus fuerzas a la vida esa es la
característica del ser humano
cuando uno logra esa parte lo primero
que hace es trascender pero que es
trascender trascender va mucho más allá
es de lo natural hacer cosas
sobrenaturales
pues
un placer estar aquí yo vengo de la
tierra más linda de la tierra en donde
los antes se agachan
somos demasiado costeños para hacer
serranos y demasiado serranos para hacer
costeños si señores yo soy lohan y con
un ramo siento aquí
cuando me preguntaban cómo había sido mi
vida
yo salí de la universidad técnica
particular de loja como economista y
tuve una vida de triunfos
a los 23 años fui gerente de mercadeo
para para ecuador y a los 26 para
latinoamérica iba volando todo lo que
había soñado lo tenía
placeres 5 estrellas
desayunaba en buenos aires senna beben
en santiago y era una vida tan
placentera tan chévere trajes 'hugo
boss' plumas montblanc y todo esa parte
de éxito
dentro de eso también tuve un hijo con
un lindo matrimonio que en ese entonces
existía
lamentablemente espero fruto de ese amor
nació paul emile y todo lo tenía no le
faltaba nada
entonces
los que somos creyentes en dios o los
que son creyentes en el universo y las
energías te da un primer campanazo te da
un primer te levantan las banderas
cuando iba volando iba todo bien salía
de una mesa de un restaurante de
negocios abrí la puerta y hasta se
abrían los cuatro seguros y el momento
que abrí
entraron cuatro personas me pusieron una
pistola en la cabeza y me secuestraron
una semana fui a parar a la frontera
norte con colombia
no me pudieron vender a mí lo vendieron
a otro así que me dejaron ahí al filo y
me apuntaron me arrodillaron y me
pusieron la pistola y engatillar me
dijeron estás de suerte cuando uno tiene
ya esa parte de avisos uno es como que
si algo pasa no algo se me viene
entonces la muerte no es la mayor
pérdida en la vida la mayor pérdida es
lo que muere dentro de nosotros mientras
vivimos yo les invito a vivir que esta
conferencia nos sirva es para vivir
cuando lo dice consiste de esa forma lo
dice desde la esencia propia de su vida
ahora
tuve ese banderazo ese campanazo del
secuestro y dejen de
no pasa nada me resbala seguía perdón
entonces un día me quedaré
y cuando me quebré me encontré en el
piso de un hospital de quito en el sur
ni siquiera en una camilla tenía cinco
fracturas 35 microfracturas cerebrales
muerto eso es morir y aparte de eso
no es suficiente con eso tenía un
divorcio encima así que no tenía plata y
luego de eso también tenía un negocio
quebrado entonces ya o sea más abajo no
puedes ir o sea como dice y ya lleva mía
si diosito entonces llegas a un punto en
que dices a ver a ver a ver espera para
para para para parar
y dices ok ya me pasó esto más abajo no
voy a ir lo que puede subir toda la
visita de un gran maestro
ese maestro excursión me dijo toma la
decisión las decisiones o te vas a morir
ahora o vas a vivir y pues tome la
decisión de vivir
dentro de las preguntas que uno se hace
cuando toma esa decisión dice a ver fui
sobreviviente o soy un superviviente
cuando te haces esa pregunta recién
entiendes el trascender y ahí lo primero
que hace el adn del ser humano es
ordenar
usted vaya a una habitación desarreglada
lo primero que hace un ser humano es
tratar de arreglar entonces lo primero
que arregle fue mi mente porque todo es
mental si usted está bien mentalmente se
puede arreglar físicamente se puede
arreglar emocionalmente y
espiritualmente no hay otra forma cuando
tome esa decisión esta es una foto que
yo la tengo siempre presente
es la última foto que tuve antes del
accidente eso fue el 23 de febrero el
accidente fue el 24 de febrero
y reímos mucho pero también en el hecho
del dolor en el hecho de la muerte
los médicos dijeron aún te vas a quedar
más menos seis meses dentro de un
hospital no vas a volver a caminar
entonces y para que todos decir no se va
a volver a recuperar las voces cuando
iba y venía de los quirófanos decía ve
ojalá quede para silla de ruedas
entonces uno dice a ver a ver a ver un
momento vamos a salir de este tema
cuando me pasó el accidente iba a dar
una conferencia en las cámaras de
comercio al tungurahua
y el accidente fue tan fatal que
murieron cuatro personas y sobrevivimos
dos entonces lo que primero que pedí
dije en silla de ruedas llévame a dar
esa conferencia en ambato
la primera conferencia creo que era para
100 personas tuvo un éxito total después
del accidente con silla de ruedas y y
todo lo demás tuve tres conferencias una
a la mañana dos en la tarde entonces
desde ahí políticamente como que si
funciona las sillas de ruedas
ahora lo importante de esto
es que tuve todo el tiempo para pensar
para planear para poner una estrategia
de lo que iba a ser mi futuro y dije ok
no quiero ser nunca más empleado detrás
por más de transnacional y por más
gerente que seas eres un empleado y voy
a decidir ser más que quién eres ese
eslogan que tienen aquí en la
universidad porque cuando uno decide ser
más es cuando uno trasciende y ahí
empezamos a pensar lo que iba a ser
el egm que es la gran manzana ahora
aprendí también lo que decía nelson
mandela que el coraje no es la ausencia
de miedo sino el triunfo sobre él el
hombre valiente no es aquel que no
siente miedo sino el que conquista ese
miedo le quiero comentar una anécdota
que yo les digo a mi hijo siempre una
vez me pregunto cuál es el héroe que más
admiras entonces él piensa que es
ironman y grecia nuevo el chapulín es
el chiquito tiene miedo
y aún así se enfrenta a sus enemigos
otra cosa es enfrentarse con el martillo
de thor
pero el mirar al chapulín entonces la
forma de vencer ese miedo nadie te dice
anda y pierden yo no tienes miedo pero
si lo vas a hacer hazlo y si tienes
miedo pues haga algo miedo ahora a los
siete meses que salí del hospital lo
primero que me fui a hacer fue
rappel me encantan los deportes extremos
entonces siempre he creído que la
satisfacción de la vida no está en
cuántas veces respiras sino en cuántas
veces te quitan el aliento lo que sea
pero esto hace esas partes
hoy no solamente basta soñar hasta dónde
te gustaría llegar no hay que creer que
puedes hacer realidad lo que propongas y
trabajar para realizar nuestros sueños
lánzate si te vas de nariz una vez
chevere lánzate dos veces pero como
cuando se juega futbol tanto las patadas
a la pelota que le pides en el palo que
un rato la un rato la metes y cuando la
metes estás listo ahora tenemos la
corporación avanzada
treinta y cinco compañías juntas hacemos
comunicación y gobernanza política no
solamente aquí en el ecuador sino fuera
también cuál es el secreto
lo que piensas lo que sientes acciona lo
es ese secreto
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]